the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hi today we begin our final block of
material in this particular course and
it's the segment entitled infinite
series and perhaps the best way to
motivate this rather difficult block of
material is in terms of the concept of
many versus infinite in many respects
this particular block could have been
given much earlier in the course but
somehow or other until we have some sort
of a feeling as to what infinity really
means we have a maturity problem in
trying to really grasp the significance
of what's going on in fact in a manner
of speaking with all of us experience
there may be a maturity problem in
trying to grasp the fundamental I this
what I shall do throughout the material
in this block is to utilize the lectures
again to make sure that the concepts
become crystallized and used in learning
exercises plus the texts plus
supplementary notes to make sure that
the details are taken care of in
adequate fashion at any rate I've
entitled today's lecture many verses
infinite and I thought the best way to
get us dialed on this was to think of a
number that's very easy to write in
terms of exponential notation let
capital n be 10 to the 10 to the 10th
power that's 10 to the 10 by the way is
10 billion or 1 followed by 10 zeros
that's 10 to the 10 billions power that
of course means if written in place
value that would be a 1 followed by 10
billion zeros and for those of you who
would like an exercise in multiplication
and long division and you want to
compute the number of seconds in a year
and what have you it turns out without
too much difficulty that it can be shown
that to write 1 billion zeros at the
rate of one per second would take in the
order of magnitude of some 32 years in
other words this number capital n
roughly speaking writing it in place
value notation at the rate of one digit
person
would take 320 years to write and you
say so what and the answer is well after
you get out that fire and by the way
this is crucial 320 years is a long time
as well say it's not a lifetime it's
more than a lifetime it's a long time
but it's finite
eventually the job could be completed
but the interesting point is that once
it's completed the next number in our
system is capital n plus 1 capital n
plus 2 capital n plus 3 within a sense
then with n as a new reference point
we're back to the beginning of our
number system in other words granted
that n is a fantastically large number
if you wanted to become wealthy to own n
dollars with more than realize your
dream but if your aim was to own
infinitely much money n would be no
closer than having no money at all n is
no nearer the end of a number system
then there's the number 1 itself there
is the story that signifies the
difference between many and infinite and
the hammer this point home let me give
you a few more examples I cleverly call
this additional examples we all know
that there are just as many odd numbers
and even numbers right the odds and
evens match up now watch the following
little gimmick right the first two odd
numbers then the first even number the
next two odd numbers then the next even
number the next two odd numbers then the
next even number and the one like this
as long as you want and no matter where
we stop even if we go to the ten to the
tenth of the tenth term no matter what
even number we stopped at there will
always be twice as many odd numbers
written on the board as there would be
even numbers in other words even though
in the long run in terms of the infinity
of each there are as many odds and evens
if we stop this process at any finite
time no matter how far out there will
always be twice as many odds as there
are evens in fact if you want to
compound this little dilemma right the
first two evens than an odd in other
words two four one six eight three ten
twelve five and you can get twice as
many evens as there are odds etc and the
whole argument again hinges on what
confusing the concept of going out very
far with going
endlessly oh let me give you another
example of two I just want to throw
these around so to at least get the mood
created as to what we're really dealing
with right now let's take the endless
sequence of numbers the sum 1 plus minus
1 plus 1 plus minus 1 and say let's go
on forever
what will this sum be now look at 1 way
of grouping these terms is in twos in
other words we'll start with the first
two terms the next two terms in other
words we can write this as 1 plus minus
1 plus 1 plus minus 1 and writing it
this way we can see that each term adds
up to 0 and the infinite sum would be 0
on the other hand if we now leave the
first two term alone and now start
looping the remaining terms and tools we
find that the infinite sum is 1 now
we're not going to argue that something
is fishy here we're not going to say I
wonder which is the right answer what we
have shown without fear of contradiction
is that the answer that you get when you
add infinitely many terms does depend on
how you group them unlike the situation
of what happens when you add finitely
many terms in other words notice the
need for order as well as the terms
themselves when you have a sum of
infinitely many terms and the key point
is don't be upset when you find out that
your intuition is defied here you say
this doesn't seem real to me it seems
intuitively false the point is our
intuition is defied why because it
doesn't apply and why doesn't it apply
it doesn't apply because our intuition
is based on visualizing large but finite
amounts not based on visualizing
infinity you see all these paradox are
stem because in our mind we're trying to
visualize infinity as meaning the same
as very large well you know now we come
to a very important crossroad after all
if infinity is going to be this
difficult a concept to handle let's get
rid of it the easy way let's refuse to
study it that's one way of solving
problems that's what I call the right
wing conservative educational philosophy
if you don't like something throw it out
the only trouble is we need it for
example why do we need it
see wipe deal with infinite sums well
cuz we need them among other places
we've already used them for example in
computing areas who have taken a limit
as n goes to infinity summation K goes
from 1 to n F of C sub K Delta X you see
and we need this limit and so the
question comes up how shall we add
infinitely many terms we have a choice
now we control the thing out but we
don't want to throw it out we need it so
the question is how shall we add
infinitely many terms and even though we
know that our intuition can get us in
trouble
we do have nothing else to begin with so
we say okay let's mimic what happened in
the finite case and see if we can't
extend that in a plausible way to cover
the infinite case let me pick a
particularly straightforward example
let's suppose I have the three numbers
which I'll call a sub 1 a sub 2 and a
sub 3 where a sub 1 will be a half a sub
2 will be a quarter and a sub 3 will be
1/8 in other words just for reasons of
identification later on and what I'm
going to be doing each term is half of
the previous one now I want to find the
sum of these three terms I want to find
a 1 plus a 2 plus a 3 now colloquially
we just say oh that's 1/2 plus 1/4 plus
1/8 and I'll just add them up but
remember how you learn to add you may
not have paid attention to it but you
learned to add as a sequence you said
I'll add the first one then the first
plus the second gives me a number that's
my second partial sum then I'll add on
the third number that will give me my
third partial sum then I have no more
numbers to add consequently my third
partial sum is by definition the sum of
these three numbers writing it more
symbolically we say look at the first
partial sum S sub 1 is 1/2 the second
partial sum is 1/2 plus 1/4 another way
of saying that is what it's the first
partial sum plus the next term which is
1/4 1/2 plus 1/4 is 3/4 then we said ok
the third partial sum is what we had
before namely 3/4 plus the next term
which was 1/8 and that gives rise to 7/8
in other words we said let's form a 1
then a 1 plus a 2 a 1 plus a 2 plus a 3
and when we finally finished
sequence of partial sums the last
partial sum was the answer and by the
way let me take time out here to hit
home at the most important point the
point that I think is extremely crucial
as a starting point if we're going to
understand what this whole block is all
about it's to distinguish between a
series and a sequence and I'll have much
more to say about this in the
supplementary notes but for now think of
it this way a series is a sum of terms a
sequence is just a listing of terms in
other words in this particular problem
do not confuse the role of the A's with
the role of the esses notice that the
A's refer to the sequence of numbers
being added in other words the A's were
what they were 1/2 1/4 and 1/8 these
were the three numbers being added
notice that the esses were the partial
sums in other words the partial sums
formed the sequence s 1 s 2 s 3 and to
refresh your memories on this that would
be the sequence what 1/2 3/4 7/8 in
other words this was the sum of the
first number that you were adding 3/4
was the sum of the next the first 2 and
7/8 was the sum of all 3 of them and
notice by the way the last partial sum S
sub 3 the sum was defined to be the last
partial sum and that is what the number
this is very very crucial 1/2 plus 1/4
plus 1/8 is the sum of three numbers but
it's one number and that number is
called 7/8 can you see what we're
talking about now we're looking at a
bunch of terms we're adding them up and
we see how the some changes with each
term in fact in terms of a very trivial
analogy think of an adding machine the
esses as you punch numbers in the esses
are the sums that you see being read as
your total sum whereas the A's are the
individual numbers being punched in to
add up ok I hope that's a trivial
example as I was to myself saying it it
sounds like it I made it harder than it
really is at any rate let's generalize
this particular problem let's suppose
now instead of wanting to add 1/2 plus
1/4 plus 1/8 we want to add up the first
end team terms of the form 1/2 plus 1/4
plus 1/8 in other words
let the ends term that we're going to
add a sub n be one over two to the N
then the nth the sum the nth partial sum
here the sum of these n terms is of
course what a 1 plus etcetera a sub n
that turns out to be 1/2 plus 1/4 plus
etc 1 over to the to the N and by the
way rather than take time to develop
this recipe over here I thought you
might like to see another place that
might be interesting to review
mathematical induction if you'll bear
with me and just come back over here
where we were computing these partial
sums notice that in each of these
partial sums notice that your
denominator is always 2 raised to the
same power as this subscript C 2 to the
first power is 2 2 to the second power
is 4 2 to the third power is a in other
words if your subscript is n your
denominator is 2 to the n notice that
your numerator is always 1 less than
your denominator in other words if your
denominator is 2 to the N the numerator
is 2 to the N minus 1
and once we suspect this this particular
result can be proven by induction I
won't take the time to do this here what
I will take the time to do is to observe
that this particular sum can be written
more conveniently if we divide through
by 2 to the end to get 1 minus 1 over 2
to the N for example suppose we wanted
to add up the 10 numbers I say 10
numbers here 2 to the 10th is a thousand
24 but according to this recipe 1/2 plus
1/4 plus 1/8 plus 1/16 plus etc etc plus
1 over a thousand 24 we had up to be
what 1 minus 1 over a thousand 24 in
other words this would be a thousand 23
over a thousand 24 which seems to be
pretty close to 1 in fact you can begin
to suspect that as n gets arbitrarily
large S sub n gets arbitrarily close to
1 in value I'm just talking fairly
intuitively for the time being but you
see the major question now is suppose
you elect not to stop at that and you
see this is a very key point we've
already seen how the whole world
seems to change as soon as you say let's
never stop as opposed to saying let's go
as far as you want see if we now say
what happens if you go on endlessly over
here well it becomes very natural to say
look at the nth partial sum was 1 minus
1 over 2 to the N in the case where you
were adding up a finite number of terms
when you came to the last partial sum
that was by definition your answer now
what we're saying is look at because we
have infinitely many terms to add there
is no last partial sum and so what we
say is look at instead of the last term
since there is no last term why don't we
just take the limit of the nth partial
sum as n goes to infinity in other words
in this particular case notice that as n
approaches infinity 1 minus 1 over 2 to
the N approaches 1 and we then define
the infinite sum meaning what I write it
this way as Sigma n goes from 1 to
infinity 1 over 2 to the N it really
means what the limit as n goes to
infinity 1/2 plus 1/4 plus 1/8 plus 1/16
endlessly
that that limit is 1 and we define that
to be the sum and again as I say I'm
going to write that in more greatly more
detail in the notes and also we'll have
many exercises on this I just want you
to see how we get to infinite sums which
are called series by generalizing what
happens in the finite case and because
this may seem a little bit vague to you
let me give you a pictorial
representation of the same thing you see
what's happening here is this draw a
little circle around one of bandwidth
Epsilon in other words let's knock off
an interval Epsilon on either side of 1
and let's call this point here 1 minus
Epsilon let's call this point here 1
plus Epsilon and what we're saying about
our partial sums is this that when you
start off and you're adding up terms
here you have 1/2 1/2 plus 1/4 brings
you over to 3/4 the next partial sum is
7/8 etc and always saying is that these
terms get arbitrarily close to 1 in
value meaning that after a while and
I'll define more rigorously what after a
while means in a moment all of the S sub
ends are within Epsilon
of what after a while all of your
partial sums are in here and what you
mean by after a while certainly depends
on how big Absalon is in other words the
smaller the bandwidth you allow yourself
the more terms you may have to take
before you get within the tolerance
limits that you allow yourself in any
event going back to something that we've
been using for a long time our basic
definition is the following if you have
an infinite sequence say a collection of
terms B sub n in other words B 1 B 2 B 3
etc without end we say that that
sequence converges to the limit our
written the limit of B sub n as n
approaches infinity equals L if and only
if for every epsilon greater than zero
we can find a number n which depends on
epsilon knows the notation here and as a
function of epsilon such that whenever
little n is greater than capital n the
absolute value of a sub n minus L is
less than Epsilon and you see again you
may wonder how in the world that you're
going to remember this if you memorize
this I guarantee you in two days time
you'll have to memorize it again I also
hope you have enough faith in me to
recognize that I didn't memorize this
there is a feeling that one gets for
this and let me give you what that
feeling is again in terms of a picture
what it means
well I'll change these two A's now
because that's the symbols that we've
been using before in terms of sequence
of terms what we really mean and I don't
care what symbol you really use here is
if you want to talk about the limit of a
sub n as n approaches infinity if that
limit equals L what the rigorous
definition says is this draw yourself an
interval around L of bandwidth Epsilon
in other words from L minus epsilon to L
plus Epsilon and what this thing says is
is that beyond a certain term say the
capital n term every term beyond the
certain one is in here all a whoa all a
ends are in here if n is sufficiently
large I don't know if you can read that
very well but just listen to what I'm
saying all of the terms are in here if n
is sufficiently large what this means
again is that to all intents and
purposes if you think of this bandwidth
as
giving you a dot see a thick dot here
where the endpoints at L minus epsilon
and L plus Epsilon
what we're saying is look at after a
certain term the way I've drawn it here
after the fifth term all the remaining
terms of my sequence are in here by the
way notice the role of the subscripts
here all the subscripts tells you is
where the term appears in your sequence
for example the third term in your
sequence could be a smaller number than
the second term of your sequence do not
confuse the size of the terms with the
subscripts the subscripts order the
terms but the third term in the sequence
can be less than in size than the second
term in the sequence but again I'll talk
about that in more detail in the notes
the point that I want you to see is that
in concept what limit does is the
following limit is to an infinite
sequence as last term is to a finite
sequence in other words a limit replaces
infinitely many points by a finite
number of points plus a dot you see
going back to this example here how many
ASA bends were there well there were
infinitely many well to keep track of
these infinitely many what do I have to
keep track of now well in this diagram
the first five A's plus this dot because
you see every one of my infinitely many
A's past the fifth one is inside the
stop see so in other words then what's
happened the thing that had to happen we
had to deal with infinite sequences we
saw the big philosophic difference
between infinitely many and just large
and so our definition of limit had to be
such that we could reduce in a way that
was compatible with our intuition the
concept of infinitely many points to a
finite number because you see as I'll
show you in the notes also all of our
arithmetic is geared for just a finite
number of operations see this is why
this definition of limit is so crucial
again you may know this and I'll remind
you of this also in the exercises that
structurally this definition of limit
is the same as the limit that we use
when we talked about the limit of f of X
as X approaches a equals L the absolute
value signs have the same properties as
before and by the way before I go on let
me just remind you again of one more
thing while I'm talking that way instead
of memorizing this remember how you read
this the absolute value of a sub n minus
L is less than epsilon means what that a
sub n is within epsilon of L that's what
we used in our diagram but it seems to
me I forgot to mention this and I want
you to see that what the key building
block analytically is the absolute value
and the meaning of absolute value is the
same here as it was in units in blocks 1
& 2 of our course so what I'm driving at
is that the same limit theorems that
we've been able to use up until now
still apply oh by means of an example
suppose I have the limit as n approaches
infinity 2n plus 3 over 5 n plus 7
notice that I can divide numerator
denominator through by n if I do that I
have the limit as n approaches infinity
2 plus 3 over n over 5 plus 7 over n now
using the fact that the limit of a sum
is the sum of the limits the limit of a
quotient is the quotient of the limits
the limit of 1 over N as n goes to
infinity is 0 notice that I can use the
limit theorems to conclude that the
limit of this particular sequence is 2/5
if I wanted to the same ways we didn't
block to in block 1 block 2 where we're
talking about limits given an epsilon I
can actually exhibit how far out I have
to go before each of the terms in the
sequence is within that given epsilon of
2/5 by the way again to emphasize once
more because this is so important the
difference between an infinite sum and
an infinite sequence observe that
whereas the limit of the sequence of
terms 2n plus 3 over 5 n plus 7 is 2/5
the infinite sum composed of the terms
of the form 2n plus 3 over 5 n plus 7 is
infinity since after a while each term
that you're adding here behaves like 2
Fifth's in other words if you write this
thing out to see what this means pick n
to be 1 when n is 1 this term is 5 12
when n is 2 this is what 7 + 17 7 17
when n is 3 this is 9 20 seconds when n
is 4 this is 8 plus 3 is 11 over 27
knows what you're saying is the infinite
sum means to add up all of these terms
the thing whose limit was 2/5 was the
sequence of terms themselves in other
words what we're saying is that after a
certain point every one of these terms
behaves like 2/5 and what you're saying
is look at after a point what you're
really doing is essentially is adding on
2/5 every time you add on another term
and therefore this sum can get as large
as you want just by adding on enough
terms again observe the difference
between the partial sums and the terms
themselves the terms that you're adding
are approaching 2/5 as a limit the thing
that's becoming infinite is the sequence
of partial sums because what you're
saying is to get from one partial sum to
the next you're roughly speaking adding
on 2/5 each time to generalize this what
we're saying is if the sequence of
partial sums converges the individual
terms that you're adding must approach 0
in the limit for if the limit of the a
sub n as n approaches infinity is is L
where L is not 0 then beyond a certain
term the sum of the a sub ends behaves
like the sum of the l's
and what you're saying is if L is
nonzero by adding on enough of these fix
tells you can make the sum as large as
you wish in other words then a sort of
negative test is that if you know that
the series converges then the terms that
you're adding on must approach 0 in the
limit unfortunately by the way the
converse is not true namely if you know
that the terms that you're adding on go
to 0 you cannot conclude that their sum
is finite again it's our old friend of
infinity times 0 you see as these terms
approach 0 as these tubes approach 0
when you start to add them up it may be
that they're not going to zero fast
enough
other words notice that the terms are
getting small but you're also adding
more and more of them you see what I
wrote here that's what on the other hand
the limit of a sub n as n approaches
infinity equals 0 is not enough to
guarantee the convergence of this
particular sum in fact a trivial example
to show this is look at the following
contrived example start out with the
first number being 1 then take 1/2 twice
1/3 3 times 1/4 4 times 1/5 5 times 1/6
6 times form the nth partial sum look at
is it clear that the terms that are
going into your some are approaching 0
in the limit you see you have a 1 then
there are halves then thirds then
fourths then fifths then 6th 7th etc the
terms themselves are getting arbitrarily
close to 0 on the other hand what is the
sum becoming well this adds up to 1 this
adds up to 1 this adds up to 1 and this
adds up to 1 and in other words by
taking enough terms I can tack on as
many ones as I want and ultimately even
though the terms become small the sum
becomes large
in fact it's precisely because of this
unpleasantness that we have to go into a
rather difficult lecture next time
talking about ok how then can you tell
when an infinite sum converges to a
finite limit and when doesn't it at any
rate that's what I said we're going to
talk about next time as far as today's
lesson is concerned I hope that we've
straightened out the difference between
a sequence in a series partial sums and
the terms being added and in the hopes
that we've done that let me say until
next time goodbye
funding for the publication of this
video was provided by the Gabriella and
Paul Rosenbaum foundation
help ocw continue to provide free and
open access to MIT courses by making a
donation at ocw.mit.edu/donate